it usually happens behind closed doors
but sometimes it's caught on camera like
in the recent case of football player
ray rice its domestic violence and it's
part of a global epidemic of violence
against women
around the world thirty percent of women
had experienced physical and/or sexual
violence at the hands of an intimate
partner forty-two percent of them
reported injuries but this isn't just a
women's issue in the US fourteen percent
of men have experienced severe physical
violence in a relationship compared to
twenty-two percent of women and that's
just what gets reported the most common
form of violence women experience
worldwide actually happens in a
relationship but despite how common it
is individual stories like janay rice
has always seemed to elicit strong
reactions why would someone like janay
rice have married her abuser she married
this guy after he did this she married
him she still married him the leaked
footage of Ray Rice's assault sparked an
onslaught of shock disgust and even
judgment of janae to the people on the
outside it seems obvious that someone in
an abusive relationship should leave but
for those actually trapped inside the
cycle of violence it's not that simple
on social victims explained why I stayed
with reasons ranging from wanting to
protect their children to not knowing
how a healthy relationship actually felt
to not believing they deserve better
then there's the fear that the abusive
partner might retaliate because the
final step in the domestic violence
pattern is kill her leaving an abusive
relationship is often the most dangerous
time for the victim I was afraid I say
hey you know I'm not gonna wear depends
but instead of asking why the victim
stays why don't we ask why does someone
abuse risk factors for becoming an
abuser include lower levels of education
witnessing family violence alcohol abuse
and mental health issues but that
doesn't cover everyone so much of how we
talk about domestic violence puts the
focus on reforming laws and getting
survivors to shelters and hot lines
which are all important but what about
prevention how can we teach people not
to abuse or to stop subscribe on YouTube
follow us on Twitter and like us on
Facebook